is that is that twitter time mom yeah
good morning you guys woke up
that would just get away yeah
yeah woke up wanted to explore as you
guys know we love being out in nature
and since we've moved to vegas there's
so much nature out here so much to see
as you guys can see around me look at
all this
we're right by lake mead you see all
that water
this is literally like a 40 minute drive
from our house um and today we're going
to explore the historic railroad trails
look at this tell them about that tell
them about the the trail tell me tell me
don't try this one
this broken that's what we're gonna get
in that's how you get in yeah but it's
gonna be it's not gonna be chilly at all
inside because big chiliad
so it was built into a mountain so
that's what we're going to be walking
obviously there's no more
trains oh
he's inside yeah so we actually get to
walk through it now never been here
before super excited to do it um so yeah
let's check it out let's get going okay
let's go
so let you know how the trail is if you
want to bring family i'm bringing taika
because it seems pretty chill as you can
see the road is paved i assume that it's
going to stop being paved once we turn
the bend there um but good news here is
i can't even see if i'm filming it is it
there oh yeah they have bathrooms right
there
so bathrooms to start the hike is always
a good sign for me cause i'm like okay
it's not gonna be that crazy especially
when i bring taika so that's already a
good start for families
all right so
that's where i was showing you where the
map was
walk this yep it's not paved anymore but
here take a note of that extreme
conditions it does get really hot out
here it can get to 1 15. when we moved
here it was 115
was the peak
oh
hell
but there you go officially do not come
june through september are you good yeah
look at that on the flip side whoa
come june through september nobody's
here
i would come here because no one's
here i don't think it's a chinese thing
i think he's just a lunatic and we can
all agree to that
come on dude
you throw a rock at the poopoo yeah what
is the poo poo sad what if he's like oh
why someone throw a rock does poo poo
have feelings
hey does poo-poo have feelings
yeah it does
happen oh actually no
okay
okay so when we met to get here there's
two ways to go about it the first one is
you can google it and then it'll give
you like the government's uh location
and that sends you somewhere
like a little bit of its location no
like the government like what the
government deems is the location of this
right so there's the government location
of it and then there's like the locals
location of it
um
and the government will take you to like
this
like um
uh
like an information type center and i
feel like that one might have to uh
might ask for a fee or something like
that i'm not too sure but
oh but you want to google i think where
it's like uh the site that shows you a
bunch of trails let me see specifically
what it is
okay
let's drop my phone
okay
you guys could watch them as i look this
up
but the
the website is called
i don't want to give you wrong
information
oh all trails that's what the thing is
called i'm sure some of you have heard
it
you did
yeah so look up this it's called the
historic i mean you saw it look it up
and it'll take you to this specific
location you want to enter through here
it is absolutely
free
okay so we're about to enter
ready to go yeah yeah i might have to
pass them to you because this rock i'm
standing on is cracking oh no okay
movies okay okay
no watch look at this my left foot okay
look i it looks like a big rock
no
did you see that okay it's an avalanche
i don't think so dude
i do
[Applause]
okay you ready to rock or do you need
help
you
okay
you got a little scratch you got a
little scratch good job
and something happens you okay are you
okay
are the raindrops falling on your head
not
[Applause]
oh my goodness oh you did it again
okay don't go up anymore we're right at
the beginning of the trail hike
this is considered a hike
trail walk trail
um and you can already see lake mead
from here you know how gorgeous
this duty is just throwing rocks hey do
you want to show them what happened to
your hands
a little bit bleeding are you scared
does it hurt you what a stud yeah but i
can do this okay go for it go for it let
me see show me
i like your throwing technique did you
know it was going in that direction and
you just kind of i like it i like how
you throw you look at the right but you
throw it through it yeah yeah i like it
too it scares me because i feel like
it's going to come right back at me
[Applause]
careful don't get too close to the edge
you're making me nervous oh my god
why do you always insist on like trying
to get naked of some sort
put your shirt down
who's your comedic inspiration are you a
chris farley type of guy yeah or jim
carrey i feel like he's a jim carrey
type of guy
you're a butthole
oh man you like that nasty launching
comedy huh
no i don't know about that
[Applause]
okay so i want to say we've been walking
now for about 20 minutes um my watch
says we've been walking about almost a
mile i want to say we've walked the mile
because it picked up kind of later um
on this on this
walk
but look how much closer we are to lake
mead
look at this
you see the boats that are all docked
and a lot of the trail for right now at
least is a lot of this like beautiful
scenic mountains
all around
it's really peaceful really quiet not
crowded at all
it's been like this like every
five seven minutes or so we'll see
someone like walk past us in the
opposite direction but it's really chill
he's been hanging in there throwing a
bunch of rocks not getting into any
trouble he's been
so parents if you're in vegas or you
visit vegas
come this way
look at that all the energy that's
getting burnt
[Applause]
come on dude
[Applause]
something's coming up
i can see it what what what what what do
you see
yeah
[Applause]
so there we go our very first
tunnel so on this trail i see it yeah
double tunnels
let's go that's crazy balls
so uh on the way up here there's a bunch
of like little information points one of
them was telling us about how this used
to be a 30 mile
um train
uh train uh
uh railroad train tracks got it i don't
know why i said that and its main
purpose was to ship materials
um to build the hoover dam because as
you guys know we're right by the hoover
dam and these trains would run 24 hours
a day just carrying materials to
construct this massive ass dam
but now obviously
it's not needed so we get to walk
through it i'm so excited this is so
cool
what are you doing i'm gonna set up a
picture for the beautiful lake teeny guy
okay job
and one of the highlights why tech is
doing that is because they do say that
there are longhorn sheep
uh bighorn sheep
that tend to climb these mountains so we
haven't seen anything yet
so we're keeping our eyes peeled
but yeah i'm excited look at that i've
never walked through one of these before
here we go approaching
the first one ready to go inside monkey
what are you thinking what are you what
are your thoughts right now are you
excited are you scared
no no no
yeah
make a wish and hold your breath what
yeah i gotta look away here we go good
morning
when you're walking but we'll do it
anyway
well they're going to do it because i'm
talking
look at how rad this is
that is crazy
that is crazy though
oh this is cool
this is sick
it's
trains used to run through here duty
isn't that cool
but not anymore yeah exactly good job
thank you to a vampire nice to know i'm
not the only mexican here
come on
you got this guy too
my jokes are so lame i like even
disappoint myself so if i annoy you you
can't try to be like me if i annoyed you
don't worry i know myself way further
this is the way i see it
[Applause]
when i say
it's mexican
vampire
in the movies yeah
yeah
yeah
we are inside
tunnel number two and as you guys saw
from the mexican free-tail
um bats there are bats that do inhabit
um some of these tunnels so
haven't seen at me yet
maybe there's just too much traffic i
feel like it'd be way too loud for them
to feel comfy here but if they say they
live here then yes they live here
looks like bart's walking into the gates
of heaven
[Applause]
oh he's out he went to hell
i'm only filming this because it looks
really cool
there's like a random
container at the end
i was just showing you
um
which leads me to believe that
they're doing some sort of construction
up there or there's some rocks that are
falling oh my god
that doesn't look very safe
[Applause]
but yeah
you're so close to the edge dude papa
what don't take a picture that's
dangerous he's scaring me you love me
[Applause]
yeah there's no wind dad
all of a sudden that's the middle of the
window
the win was so last week
okay so we've been walking about an hour
now getting a little bit hungry taika is
showing signs of being a little bit
tired so we're gonna just visit this
last
tunnel right there i don't know if you
can see it
and from that point we'll turn back
around
i'm just so curious to see
what's on the other side for one i wish
we'd go further
um but you know with little legs and
he's been like sprinting he'll sprint
and then he'll stop he'll sprint and
then he'll stop so i think he really
just wore himself out which is good
because
it's almost his nap time he's four
so naps are very much
a thing
instead of taking multiple naps today
at this age he takes one
and they're like
on
schedule so
it's gonna perfectly aligned oh
okay so i see it approaching
and behind that tunnel i see another
tunnel
let's see let's see what happens let's
see what happens
[Applause]
all right so we're walking back to our
car we're at the beginning of the trail
as you can see right behind me this is
what we walk through
um
[Applause]
yep
and i do want to give some of my first
time pro tips
um
i would say
you can definitely bring a dirt bike
here as you can see the gravel is
actually not too bad pretty smooth
obviously there you don't want to go so
if you have any kids that are under four
how do you give me a mountain bike a
bike or mountain bike dirt bike is
gasoline
oh is that what i said a dirt bike oh my
mystic
um
if you have kids i would say this is
kind of a challenging walk in terms of
distance
um we got up to that third so you saw
that third tunnel and that was about
one and a half miles
from that point forward and backwards we
walked about three miles which is nice
right because it's a nice smooth walk
and if you're trying to get some cardio
in this is a really cool trail for
cardio
um we didn't bring water but we are also
kind of like camels we don't really run
off of too much water and we we were
pretty minimalist when it comes to
travel so as you can see i have nothing
except
my phone on me bring some clothes that
you don't mind getting dirty and shoes
so as you can see tiger's shoes were
black
but i mean this is his going out
get dirty clothes bring something
comfortable again you don't want to get
dirty
right now it is about
64 degrees out
and it's pretty warm it's comfortable
it's not too hot but when you do walk in
the shaded areas which can be pretty
lengthy it gets cold instantly so if
you're someone like me that gets cold i
would say carry like a light little
jacket or sweater this is literally all
i'm wearing
um i have leggings on high socks because
i don't want to get dirt
inside my shoes or around my ankles
um
next time we come i am going to bring
some type of like
stroller or wagon and i'm going to bring
food so that we can stop midpoint
because i do want to see what's at the
end of this thing um but because i have
a little four-year-old he gets tired so
there's a bunch of benches along the way
that you can sit and kind of coast
but all in all i would say i really like
this hike it was super chill really
scenic um it was fresh there's enough
shade
uh because as you can see you're walking
right by alongside the mountains i can't
wait to come back honestly because i
want to be more prepared either bring in
the stroller or wagon or something for
this dude
um bringing some food a little bit of
water
uh so that we can just kind of stop at
each bench and stop pointing just kind
of take things in
slow down last a little bit longer and i
just want to see what's at the end of it
because rumor has it you can walk all
the way to hoover dam from this point i
don't know what the distance is between
this point to getting to the hoover dam
area
but yeah i'm excited to come back when
friends come over
and i want to show them a different side
of vegas for sure i'm bringing them here
it was really really cool and again like
i said it's free
so now we're going to wrap it up i want
to say thank you so much and if you like
these videos let me know
um because i always find it so hard to
find things to do for families when i
google it like what's something to do in
vegas
off the strip and it gives me like some
weird stuff um so i've just kind of been
finding papa and i have been finding
these things on our own or just through
asking different locals that have
families so if you want to get more of
this insider local
tip of what to do let me know and uh
yeah we'll keep recording this stuff
because i love exploring this area i
love learning more things to do with
this dude especially if it's free so
yeah thank you so much for watching and
we'll see you tomorrow